hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the us women's
championship it's uh karissa yip versus
tatev abrahamian a lot of you guys have
requested this one not this game
specifically you requested me to show a
game by karissa if she won the us
women's chess championship one round
well with one round to the spare
and it's definitely an incredible
achievement and it was not easy to
choose a game to show because all of her
games are really uh fierce attacking
games most of them very short so you
guys will enjoy uh pretty much all of
them pick any and you know just to go
through it uh that you will have to do
on your own but this is the one that i
chose um she's playing against the women
international uh grand master tatev
abrahamian
and it's really
a really cool game and it features a
really cool positive video moment that
i'm sure you guys will enjoy so without
further ado let's check it out and we're
gonna
show the
will
her score in in the tournament uh after
we check out the game uh so uh uh
karissa with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e6 by abrahamian going for
the french defense we have d4 d5 and uh
karissa advances the e5 pawn going for
the advanced variation of the french
we have c5 striking in the center and
now c3 so very very standard stuff
knight to c6 and knob knight to f3 the
pulse and attack
and the queen to b6 and this is a
very standard when you go for this line
of the french and it's very annoying if
you're unfamiliar with it because black
is putting so much pressure towards that
d4 pawn and you are unclear on how to
continue here because well if you play
something like bishop to d3 then the
queen no longer defends the d4 pawn so
black could just capture it you can't
play bishop to e3 because then queen
captures on b2 so i'm sure you guys had
this many time on the board when you
played against the french and you were
just like what what do i do here and you
were too lazy to check after the game so
i'm just going to tell you here you can
play bishop to d3 as this is what
karissa played in the game and give up
the d4 pawn but not really because after
c captures on d4 uh you don't have to
give up the pawn you could just capture
back the pawn can never be captured
because after knight captures queen
captures bishop b5 check wins the black
queen so your pawn is never in any
actual danger but here uh charissa just
uh castles and she offers the the pawn
here so really making it upon sacrifice
now you could do this knight captures on
c3 it's perfectly fine but maybe not
give white
so much development especially as
karissa here is known to be a fierce
attacker so instead after castles with
bishop to d7 continuing development and
now rook to e1 adding another defender
here uh but also putting the rook on the
uh on the e file that the king still
occupies so knife g to e7 the knight can
now come to the f5 or g6 and we have the
immediate h4 so now if knight g6 we can
always just kick it away with h5 and for
the moment knight f5 is ill-advised
because we are definitely capturing this
to
really mess up black spawn structure so
here we have a6 and now h5 grabbing more
space on the king side
and there uh is a game that uh reached
this exact same position where g6 was
played it was in the game moment of
marco from the uh affiliate online not
feed it from the online olympiad uh is
it defeated online olympiad i have no
idea uh i know it's some olympiad but uh
let me just quickly check is it the
uh yeah it's just the online olympiad i
imagine it's the feta olympiad uh
no it's the it's the chess.com uh
olympia so sorry about that yeah but
regardless the the position is known and
this is the move that was played but
here we have h6 and it is now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
this is where our game truly begins
so here we have queen to e2 uh nicely
developing the queen
and uh here comes f5 you could go for
the captures on c3 now and here it might
even make sense uh maybe after d
captures on c3 uh you're gonna have to
capture with the beep on maybe capturing
with the knight is now a bit too
optimistic because then knight to d4
could be a problem so it's it's perhaps
in the position but okay here we have f5
now hoping that uh the this stays intact
of course if white captures up a song
could be very dangerous
but this is exactly what white goes for
e captures an f6 alpha song and now g
captures on f6 and it looks very shaky
uh but if there's nothing here for white
then black just has a beautiful center
here and not a worry in the world you
also have the uh or semi-open g file to
use for attacking uh you might shift the
knight bring the bishop to c6 uh
obviously not that arrow chess.com
uh but uh yeah there is a
a lot of attacking potential for black
here as well but here we have c captures
on d4 knight captures on d for knight
captures queen captures and now bishop
to e3 so white uh
indian is down upon but
get some development for it and here we
have queen to e5 uh this is uh perhaps a
bit uh too dangerous queen to h4 on the
other hand uh is very very strong uh the
thing is white's plan is to play bishop
c5 eliminate the knight and play bishop
to g6 check and this would really
[ __ ] the black king but here after
bishop to c5 you can simply play rook to
c8 for the moment you don't care about
this because in this position it doesn't
really work captures captures bishop to
g6 check you can move the king and the
position is fine for black black might
even be in time for some king to
c7 to b8 action but also the king
could be just fine here in the center of
the board so not a lot to worry about
here for black but instead queen the e5
was played and this gives white um a lot
more a lot more space you know to to do
some stuff so knight the d2 trying to
offer the the b2 pawn but of course
grabbing that pawn now uh when none of
your pieces are
really developed runs into a lot of
trouble for example here you'd
you'd this would be met with knight to
c4 and this is not really crazy uh going
for knight to d6 check and especially if
the queens uh get traded off the board
then just knight the d6 check king the
d8 and bishop to b6 is checkmate a
beautiful knight in bishop checkmate
where you don't even care about the
black queen so this is uh you know in
the position if uh if you're not careful
so here we have rook to g8 like we said
we really want this bishop on c6 going
after this g2 pawn and now f4 yeah we
have to kick away the the black queen uh
queen to d6 and now queen to f2 again
we're trying to get that bishop to c5
move in the queen will move we're gonna
pick up the knight and then we're to
play bishop to g6 check now it
definitely makes sense to block this
rook's uh reached uh
towards the g2 pawn so rook the c8 black
stops this now controls the c5 square
sufficiently and now rook a to d1 here
knight to b3 also a nice continuation
you really want to fight for that c5
square but rook 8 to d1 in the spirit of
adolf anderson uh really
makes sense because now the king is in
the center the rooks are on a1 and e1
and this uh well more often than not uh
accomplishes a lot in chess
and this is a
one such example so here you really have
to play something like f5 uh you have to
i'm not gonna tell you why you have to
play f5 but it's for a very good reason
instead black played bishop to c6 now
finally putting the bishop on this
diagonal so once you advance this pawn
it could be very dangerous
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out the reason why i chose
this game to show you from all the
others
you know while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh
miraculous idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course bishop h7 that's the good stuff
yes uh it looks like a move that does
nothing
because i'm sure you guys are asking
yourselves okay rook g7 and what happens
well what happens is that the bishop is
no longer on the d file and that's the
idea we want to move the bishop away
from the d file with tempo that's why we
attacked the road we couldn't just move
it to b1 because there's no threat here
black has to waste the move moving the
rook otherwise we're just going to pick
up that rook so here knight to e4 and
now you can see that the queen is
attacked but also the f6 spawn
and the f6 pawn cannot be defended the
the e5 square is covered by the pawn so
you have to move the queen queen to c7
was played and now uh knight captures on
f6 is perfectly fine this comes with
check but uh uh
plays bishop to b6 she wants uh to get
in one more useful move because before
playing this knight captures on f6 but
of course now black doesn't allow this
i mean it would just be
a pointless to play a game like this so
black tries the only thing that's left
and that's to give up the queen for two
pieces so here we have d captures on e4
bishop captures on c7 and now rook
captures on h7 so bishop to d6 uh white
is now winning but of course white still
has to work for his meal that's why
maybe capturing on f6 right away with
check uh would be
a a bit quicker but uh you know no one's
in any uh hurry here so rook back to g7
again we really want to open up this
diagonal and start attacking the white
king and now rook the c1 so now of
course if a move like e3 is played it
looks very very dangerous but we can
capture this and now what do you play
well you could play rook captures on g2
with check but after king f1 there is
really no good continuation here for
black i mean you are attacking but you
don't have all that many pieces to
attack with and white already has a
threat white can pick up the bishop and
then pick up the rook so it's uh you
know
not the maybe the uh the greatest of
ideas even though it seems like yeah
this is you know completely crushing uh
so instead we have knight to f5
attacking the bishop so bishop captures
here king captures and now rook captures
an e4 of course now the bishop cannot
capture as the rook on c8 is hanging so
rook to d8 now threatening to pick up
the rook and now we simply eliminate
this rook now of course we don't allow
rook captures here so rook captures on
c6 b captures and now rook captures an
e6 going after this pawn so knight to g3
uh not not uh going for this pawn but
going for some uh counter-attacking
chances now if you do nothing then uh
something like rook to d1 check king h2
and rook to h1 might be checkmate as the
rook uh on uh g7 is guarding the knight
and g3 however after rogue captures on
f6 checking the e7 uh we have queen to
c5 check and this is the
really just a beautiful finishing touch
now the king doesn't really have any
squares so you could capture the rook
but of course we all know uh
where that ends uh you guys have seen
the thumbnail
uh so if k8 we're just gonna play queen
to f8 to check and now we're gonna pick
up this rook so of course completely
winning for white uh so instead king
captures on f6 was played but now just
queen to e5 check king to f7 you have to
guard this rook and now queen to c7
check and he was in this position on
move 33 that tatava bahamian resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here if you move the king here then
you lose this rook and if you move the
king somewhere else then you lose this
rook so you can't keep an eye on on both
rooks
so really really an impressive game and
especially this uh
bishop to h7 move such a
such a
wonderful idea uh and
like i said the game maybe could have
been a bit different if knight captures
on f6 was played but both continuations
are winning this one just makes you work
for mila a little bit harder so so i
don't forget let's just check out uh how
she did against some of the other
players so here you can see that she
started with the draw then a win uh so
this is uh that we've shown again uh
again from round two then a draw then a
win against irena crush or the only uh
grand master in the in the
tournament uh really uh
a weird game uh where uh irina just uh
blundered a piece uh move 22 i believe
uh but i mean it happens uh then a loss
uh and then five wins in a row and
that's enough she doesn't even have to
play the final round and she still wins
the women's u.s championship so that's
incredibly incredibly impressive i mean
getting five uh wins in a row in in a
tournament of your peers is uh i mean
that's something that's something
caruana does when he has a good
tournament so really congratulations uh
and uh very very impressive stuff uh so
that's the game hope you guys uh enjoyed
it uh i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to zugswang uh and to danush
hope you guys uh you know have a really
awesome day and spend it with some
friends you know don't just uh play
chess all day uh and i would like to
thank jonathan turak charles caron and
david farney for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the usgs
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the chess world uh so
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day